SPEAKER 1: Apigee consists
of the following two
primary components--
Apigee Services,
which are the APIs
that you use to create, manage,
and deploy your API proxies,
also known as the Apigee APIs.
Next is the Apigee
Runtime, which
is a set of containerized
services in a Kubernetes
cluster that Google maintains.
All your API traffic
passes through it.
Additionally, Apigee uses
other Google Cloud Services,
such as identity management,
logging, analytics, metrics,
and project management function.
And then there are
backend services
used by your apps to provide
runtime access to data.
To get started with setting up
your environment with Apigee,
you can choose to create
an evaluation or a paid
environment.
In this video, I will share
the differences between the two
and how to start off with
the evaluation version, which
is also known as a
test or eval org.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before diving into
Apigee, you need
to have a Google Cloud
billing account created
or have management access to
that Google Cloud project.
With that in place, you can
create an evaluation org.
And when you are
ready, you can purchase
a paid version that requires
a contract with Google.
Now the key differences
are the following.
An evaluation org
is time-limited
and lacks the scalability and
flexibility of production orgs.
Although an eval
org is free of cost,
you do need to set up a billing
account in your Google Cloud
project.
But Google covers
your cost, and the org
is deleted after 60 days.
And finally, when using the
UI to provision your eval org,
you will have fewer
options than if you did so
via the command line.
For this video, we
will walk through how
to create an evaluation org.
It is very similar to that
of creating a paid org.
And in this video's
description, I
have linked several
helpful resources.
So let's dive in.
Creating an Apigee
evaluation org
is straightforward and can
be done using the UI, wizard,
or command line.
There's also a GitHub script
for the command line simplifying
that approach.
Let's use the wizard, since this
is the simplest and quickest,
which is in the Docs.
First, I enter the
name of my project,
or I can choose to
create a new one.
Note that the wizard
detects that it is not
a project with paid
entitlements and can only
be used for evaluation.
Next, click the Edit icon next
to APIs and choose Enable APIs.
This takes a couple of
minutes to complete.
A check will display next
to the Enable APIs step,
and the Networking
step will be available.
Click Edit next to Networking.
The Set Up Networking
pane is then displayed.
Select a network from the
authorized network dropdown
list.
For most eval orgs,
you select the network
that Google Cloud created when
you created your Google Cloud
project, called
Default. However,
if you have a custom
network and peering range,
you want to use select
it from the list.
For this example, I will
choose Default, Connect.
Next, I will select the option
Automatically Allocate IP
Range.
But if you already have one or
wish to create one yourself,
you can select the desired
option from the dropdown.
The IP range is for peering
between your Google Cloud
project and Apigee,
and the process also
takes a couple of
minutes to complete.
Now that networking
is configured,
we can provision the org.
Select the analytics and
runtime regions closest to you.
Click Provision.
This can take anywhere
from 20 to 30 minutes.
Once the organization
has been provisioned,
you will get an
email notification.
Your Apigee evaluation
is ready to use.
Let's go back to the
wizard and move on
to configuring access routing.
This allows you to
configure access
to your Apigee endpoint, either
internally or externally.
Internal limits access
to the Apigee endpoint
to VMs in your GCP project.
This is the internal
load balancer.
External allows access to your
APIs over the public internet
through the configuration
of an HTTP global load
balancer with a public
static IP address.
Creating an external
load balancer
can incur fees for up to $20
to $25 in your project, which
can be covered by the
free project credits
I linked again in
the description.
For this example, I will choose
the external option, which is
called Enable Internet Access.
You now have the option
to configure the hostname.
If you have access
to a DNS registry
and have an existing domain,
you can enter your own hostname
and then create a new DNS record
for your hostname pointing
to the static IP address.
If you do not have
a hostname, you
can use a wild card DNS
service, such as nip.io,
which is suggested.
It will give you a hostname
using the external IP
address of the global load
balancer with a domain suffix
nip.io.
With this approach,
Google automatically
provisions and manages
the SSL certificates
for the global load balancer.
This is the easiest
and quickest path
to getting your org operational.
And here's what that would
look like when finished.
Alternatively, you can
specify your own hostname
from a domain you own.
I have entered
mine, which becomes
the hostname for my APIs.
This also shows us the runtime
location and the internal load
balancer for the
Apigee endpoint.
It's now asking for a subnet.
And I can choose an option
in the dropdown, which
in this case is
called Default and is
in the same region
as the runtime.
I then have the option to use
my own SSL certificates and key.
Or I can skip this
by leaving it blank
and have Google create and
manage them automatically.
This is the easiest.
Then select Set Access.
Note, this step can take
about 10 minutes to complete.
In this step, you can see the
progress of each component
being created.
Upon completion,
choose Continue.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Here we can see that
Apigee has provided the IP
address of the global
load balancer, which I now
use to create an entry
in my DNS configuration.
So let's go ahead and do that.
In this example, our domain
is hosted on Google Domains.
Here I create a
new custom record
using the prefix of Type
A, and add the IP address,
then click Save.
This will take about 10 minutes
to propagate on Google Domains
but may vary depending
on your domain host.
Once that happens,
I can choose Launch
to see the "Hello, Guest!"
response from the
Hello World proxy
that Apigee created for us.
Great.
Now we can go to
the Apigee console
and begin creating
our own proxies, which
we have a video for you to
reference as a next step.
And there you have it,
a quick walkthrough
on how to create your first
evaluation org in Apigee
using the wizard interface.
And friends, if you found
this episode helpful,
you can click Like or
subscribe to our channel
for more content like this.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]